all right so let's get started because
we want to talk about how guys uh can
get exploited today and quite badly and
the first thing we have on the list that
we're going to talk about is marriage
so
who's all been married here i know
jaren's been married
50 shades too
yeah i was down for 13 years 13 yeah
josh and moth you guys never got there
right i i got the sales pitch many a
time but i just never quite you know
bought into it so
why were you supposed to be engaged
right now but uh thank god it happened
yeah i mean like your thing started a
year ago so that's been an interesting
jury so why did you guys turn turn down
man marriage because josh i mean you
ended up saying that you know you had
the proposal a few times come up
uh well it just was one of those things
where
we looked at it objectively and honestly
like
saw no real upside to it it's like okay
i've got a fork i'm promising to forgo
exercising all these other options out
here um and there's a huge amount of
liability and so i don't know kind of
having seen a lot of my friends go
through the divorce machines like pretty
early on
that to me was just kind of like a
little bit of a signal like okay if i
want to go down this pathway and get
married like why what is my actual
upside um and you know currently as a
guy i just really don't really see that
much upside unless it's really all about
right that transfer of assets but
there's ways that you can do that with
like a trust or or a will these days so
i don't you know see the need to get the
government involved in my personal
affairs what about you moth why didn't
you guys ever get there
well it ended before we got to that
point i've always been long on marriage
i mean i used to even say when i was
with my previous ltr like i used to tell
people like yeah i don't really want to
get married but i probably still will
that was like my blue pill thing um
and so but i mean you know even finding
this stuff and and even understanding
now more so the dangers and the risks of
family court system everything like that
uh i have yet to be i've yet to hear a
compelling argument from anyone
about
what you can do in a marriage that you
can't do outside of it
besides maybe some some tax breaks and
not having not being forced or compelled
to testify against a spouse but
hopefully
knock on wood i'm never going to be in a
position like that but uh yeah i've
always been sort of long on it and now
even more so after being you know
unplugged even kind of doubling and
tripling down on that would you ever get
married
i i can't see a situation where i would
um
i'm pretty open about that i mean
again i'd have to have a very compelling
argument or some things would have to
drastically change in the next
10 to 15 years when it comes to family
court
i don't think that's gonna happen in
anyone's lifetime on this panel though
um
so so i don't really see a reason to do
so
um i would say
very very unlikely
so i mean to the married guys here
how do how do guys get exploited in uh
marriage
or to the
previously married guy sorry
i think it's a it's a lot of plugged in
narrative when you're you know guys in
their late 20s are constantly been told
you're a failure if you're not looking
to settle down and wife a chick up
whereas you know if a guy's pursuing a
career and he's not wiping a chick up
he's going to be told by
been plugged in and by everything that
he needs this to complete his life
whereas if you're a career woman oh you
go girl you'll be a career girl but you
know on the other hand you you gotta you
gotta complete your life and and that's
all part of being plugged in it's like
you'll get these young men wandering
around and they'll be having the time of
their lives and they'll get whispered in
their ear from other family members so
you need to do this now you need to do
that now
and they'll you know they'll go ahead
and they'll write that too
yeah
yeah what about you did you get any of
that
yeah and my in my case it wasn't the
family pressure me so much it's more
that i'm a product of divorce raised by
a single mom so i call myself son of a
single mom oldest son of a single mom
which means you're the surrogate husband
that you essentially take over the
fatherhood responsibilities in the
family so i never really had my own
childhood and i always wanted to be able
to give that to my own kids i wanted to
have like a real family and to
exacerbate things i at about at the age
of eight or so i went to live with my
grandparents who were very old school um
german immigrants came like 40s 50s time
frame when all the world is crazy back
the last time it was crazy it's getting
crazy again
um
and they're still married they've been
married for 70 some odd years
yeah they've been married for 70 years
in fact i was with them this last
weekend before i came back to mexico and
um
it's at the point where as a kid i
always thought like okay this is ideal
like they they showed me a model of what
a good healthy happy family could look
like whereas my parents did not so i
kind of had both options like well i
want to go this route however that is an
old recipe that doesn't work in the
modern world to the point where when i
saw him this weekend they both told me
like yeah if you want to have kids
that's fine but you don't have to get
married anymore i'm like okay so even
even 100 almost 100 year old people are
starting to get it um that it's just not
the right time and place for that
anymore
yeah like the i i'm kind of in the same
you know space as uh josh and what 50
shades was talking about it's like
there's there's not a lot of advantages
to a guy to getting married
it's it's mostly risk and mostly
downside
unfortunately and i say unfortunately
you know it's you know sort of like a
tag onto that because
we've all heard the [ __ ] disney
stories growing up you watch the sitcom
tvs with the happy families and the
cosby's and the tim taylors and that
sort of thing
and it's like
okay well that's just tv and that's
media and stuff but in real life
after you talk to a few guys that get
divorced it's like holy [ __ ] like is it
really that bad and then you experience
it yourself and like hmm it is that bad
that's that's that's kind of interesting
right so it's like
what is the advantage to getting married
today for men like is there anything
that exists
uh i mean like the like i'm not opposed
to the idea of it right like having a
union with a long-term partner and being
able to combine families and everything
but the problem i mean like a marriage
is is basically inviting the church and
the state into your life yeah once you
start intertwining those things that's
why i think you know things really get
kind of um and i mean like you don't
even have to get married to invite the
state into your life because if you live
with a woman in a common law state right
the government basically looks at you
like marriage so if
seven years down the road even if you
don't have kids or if you have kids you
still have to deal with everything that
you acquired together
living as you know what the state like
when i say stay away from marriage i
also mean stay away from anything that
the government looks at like marriage so
like common law you know for example
go forward
i think historically
um marriage served a purpose back when
people are like a little more religious
and we didn't have the global sexualized
marketplace where really like even when
i was in high school my first girlfriend
was my girlfriend because my last name
is scott and her last name started the
letter really close to it and we just
got sat next to each other in
alphabetical order but outside of that
intimate social group we didn't really
have access to anyone else so it even
then it still kind of made sense but i
think back in the day really
the history of it was just it was like a
public pledge in front of god and your
community and this and that that like
okay these two were coming together to
have kids and to procreate and to
continue the community values but again
i think that's an outdated model whereas
if you want to have kids you can still
do it there's really no reason to get
married anymore and i always make the
point too i'm in latin america where
they do the civil wedding in the
religious wedding and no one ever cares
about the civil wedding it's always the
religious wedding that's actually
important to them so keep that in mind
too
yeah there's a there's a really good
book by stephanie coombs called the
history of marriage and and going back
throughout history what she did was she
went through court records
pers and personal diaries was like the
most accurate source of the information
that that that she used to put the book
together and it wasn't so much about
like love or any of those things it was
about the acquisition of in-laws it was
like
at a time where you didn't have law
enforcement you didn't have schooling
you didn't have hospitals
and
you
would benefit from blending your life
and your family with that of a woman in
her family you know land might come into
the equation a bunch of sheep and cattle
and chickens and [ __ ] like that farm
equipment but you know if you needed
medical assistance you would basically
go to the family if you needed schooling
the family if you needed child care the
family sort of thing so you know like
the acquisition of in-laws was a huge
benefit back in those days right but i
mean you know today we live in a world
where women walk around with this
preconceived notion that they don't need
no man and a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle sort of thing right
well it's still a lot of places in the
east too i mean eastern i mean that's
what it's always been about that's why
the divorce rate is so low is because
it's about you know the idea of a
romantic love and two people in holy
matrimony is a very western concept um
you know marriage still marriage
traditionally has been about
sharing assets community family the
joining of people to
uh be able to help and support one
another and that's still common in some
places but certainly not here in the
west and it's a very recent if you look
at the history of it right a very recent
idea and notion that's you know become
kind of highly corporatized so even as a
younger
kid you know always like was interested
in you know following the trail of money
right as they say like seeing where it
leads and i mean one of the ways in
which you know people get exploited is
just look at weddings themselves right
they cost an incredible amount you can
literally call up one venue and say hey
i'm having a party with 300 people it's
a birthday party okay great here's one
price oh it's that same venue that exact
same day same number of people oh it's a
wedding magically it's four times the
cost right so already you're getting
exploded off the bat before you've even
like signed the paperwork
i wouldn't be surprised if at some point
western society goes back like the harem
type thing at more of a mainstream level
or like most most of the guys in the
know like we already like the mltr type
thing i think that's gonna become more
and more mainstream especially as we hit
our next financial crisis in the middle
the problem with that gets carved out
yeah i mean the problem with that is
that when you run into situations where
there's highly successful wealthy men
that that don't
uh get into a monogamous relationship is
all of the guys that don't end up with
women end up causing some serious
problems for society i'm not saying you
know it's good or bad either way i mean
like do whatever the hell you want you
know
you guys do what suits you that's what
the concept of mental point of origin
boils down to is what is it that serves
you i mean if you want to have
children with three different women and
you know you take care of them three
different homes and run some girlfriends
you can do that right i mean you want to
be monogamous do whatever you want right
as long as it's a choice but at the end
of the day guys it's like
there really isn't any advantage
whatsoever to a guy inviting the
government into his life to decide what
happens with his wealth with access to
kids that he fathers
i mean you go to the forbes list of the
richest people in the world i think the
top whatever 100 billionaires and
there's a few women
you know like in that list and all of
the women in that list that ended up in
that category acquired their wealth how
by divorce right and inherited these
top riches the top 10 richest women in
the world all acquire their wealth
through divorce or inheritance so it's
like you know what is the advantage to a
guy
to
live in a way that the government views
as a marriage whether you take vows or
you live together common law without
some kind of protective mechanism in in
place a piece of paper or prenatal
whatever happens to work where you live
it's just it just doesn't make any sense
i mean if you want to have kids have
kids but at least be uh precise about
how you structure that in your life i
mean i was talking to 50 shades before
we went live about cars and he's like
yeah you know i'll spend 12 to 18 months
researching a car before i buy it men
don't even spend that amount of time
vetting a woman you know for mother
stock not even close
right you know we'll want to figure out
how many liters is a trunk hold how big
is the gas tank how many miles per
gallon what kind of headroom do we get
in there does the sunroof tilt up and go
back does it just tilt up like all these
things guys will spend hours and days
trying to figure out to make sure they
get the best one but the first girl that
touches his pee pee he'll go and put a
baby in her and you know screw up his
life seven to ten years down the road
well
i always say the easiest thing for me
it's the
easiest the most simple way to
understand is if you're going to jump
out of a plane and i handed you a
parachute that only had a 50 chance of
opening would you still jump
and even if it does open it's not going
to give you a soft landing yeah i'm rich
what what you said on your opening
statement was guys getting exploited by
marriage and this is one of my theories
you know about being plugged in they're
to this idea of marriage if if it was
you know before mass media and you had
open eyes what you know your eyes were
wide open going into it about what it
was for what the purpose was but this
whole disney vacation
corporatization commercialization of
everything is selling young men and
young women out there this absolute
nonsensical notion and oh it's all to
suck money out of you and and that's it
like we're not per se against marriage
we're just like you don't have your eyes
wide open and know what you're going
into here and it's not going to be like
a disney channel and it's not going to
be like a matthew mcconaughey rom-com
okay get over that it's going to be more
like um rabbit in your pot and your bank
account empty
just 50 50.
the sad reality is a lot of guys do want
to get married i i know
most younger guys that call into like
moff and i show or guys that reach out
to me for coaching consulting um when i
was young i always wanted to get married
oh like first girlfriend in high school
the goal was to go to college and get
married like i wanted kids i still want
kids but you don't have to be married to
do that and a lot of guys are plugged in
like we have retards in the comments
right now
literally putting out disney lives i
don't know what they're doing watching
watching stuff like this but hey you
know some people like to live in misery
i suppose
yeah
yeah just like you know when you think
about it it's you know you got the
financial risk you got the risk of not
even being able to raise your own
children
right
you then you run into the other problems
that you know ties in with marriage that
most guys don't even contemplate like
99.9 of men don't contemplate the fact
that they're going to have to go through
resisting the banatization through a
thousand concessions process all guys
will will end up going through the
process they'll all get beta's highs to
some to some degree it's just how much
like how badly do they resist it
basically there's a lot of things and
the tough part is is that you know again
we have that oh what's up paul
what up
well yeah the tough part really about
that is right is again like it's going
back to jaron's earlier point right
where even the older generations right
they're starting to see and realize
right that the world in which right that
idea and construct could be supported by
that notion no longer exists anymore so
again if you're taking an idea that's
designed for a certain set of conditions
and you find yourself in an environment
that no longer has those type of
conditions you have to as they say right
adapt and change with the times yeah one
of the things that i've that i've heard
um said a few times before is
um the way that a marriage contract you
know essentially works i mean if you
were to take the
you know the love and the sex and the
kids out of the equation all sort of
thing and just call it like an agreement
that two parties have to sign sort of
thing
if you were to apply that agreement to a
business partnership
the
the guy that's taken on the role that's
benefiting from the female part of the
contract
would basically be told to go [ __ ]
himself right like like you'd punch him
in the face if he showed up with a
contract that was that one-sided but
guys don't understand that it is that
one-sided until they go through the
machine and they get divorced and
they're like oh now i've experienced
that now i know what it's really like
and now i know why
men post divorce commit suicide at rates
10 times higher than women right and
they start to like okay now i'm
unplugging paul you used to be married
yeah it was fun yeah you gonna do it
again
oh yeah probably not are you gonna rush
right into that or what what's your take
on on how guys get exploited by marriage
well it's it's social conditioning and
this is a big thing that i'm dealing
with
what we all in some way shape or form
we're dealing with with guys and i even
had it presented in
um some you know some stuff with uh
training even you know dealing with uh
how to interview people and
things like that in military right like
stuff like that and um
it's just like you re the idea is that
everyone is programmed like your free
will is not as free
as you think that it is right you know
you start off yeah and so you start off
as a kid
being
you know susceptible to programming
because you're not emotionally or
mentally mature yet and so it's usually
caretakers
in your social circles when you when you
as you grow up
they instill
morals values ideas beliefs and ways of
looking at the world you respond to
stimulus and things that happen
and then if you find yourself as an
adult trying to make the decisions that
you think are going to get you happiness
and get you what you want but the
problem is all that stuff is programming
by somebody else's standards
and that standard may or may not serve
you right like the the marriage paradigm
served
a society a group of churches
tax you know attack system and things
like that and now actually a system of
divorce and remarry
um and single moms and all the stuff you
see now really serves consumerism in a
lot of ways as well
and so when you just look at there's a
lot of self-interest
and self-interested parties that impart
these ideas
and people have to latch onto these
ideas because most people can't lead
themselves right most people are yeah
right so that's that's the scariest
thing to be able to do
is to challenge this programming and to
realize that everything you've been told
and everything you've been taught
everything that you believe is true
is potentially not true that's very
scary for a lot of people it's when you
know we've you talked about it rich i
i've talked about it before too the safe
world theory
you know they have to believe in
something in certain things in order to
feel safe to operate the world
and you
break apart some of this programming and
say well you know let's challenge this
idea of marriage for a minute there's
people out there who can't have that
conversation with you like an adult they
turn into
a pile of emotions they dig their heels
in more you bring up data it's no
different than having a internet
conversation about politics or something
right it's people have these ideas they
have to cling to them and so people are
watching i mean every topic we're going
to go through
whatever your idea you think your idea
is just challenge it now that's all you
know just be not unafraid to challenge
it and and st you know look try to be
willing to look past your biases
and at the end of the day you have to
ask yourself what results are you
getting as well
um
i wasn't getting the results in the
marriage i was in but i don't have this
terrible story about marriage
i have
it we ended as good as that could end
and we have a great relationship so
things don't have to go because another
paradigm is that also when you break up
and the divorce happens that it has to
be toxic you have to fight each other in
court and it has to be bad for the kids
so people stay for the children and they
stay to preserve their resources and for
all the wrong reasons of staying now
there's another person there and that
person may not you might not have
control over that person right so there
may be problems there but i was lucky my
ex is not this terrible human being we
get along great we co-parent our kid and
it's everything's fine but that's not a
normal story either it's just the point
is though
people stay in the marriage because of
another set of paradigms that they're in
well i gotta stay for the kids because
if i leave you know i'll lose half my
stuff and i don't know what that looks
like i won't be able to see my children
or it'll be bad for the kids growing up
no i think being that what's bad for the
kids really is being in a house with two
people who don't really care about each
other and are in a business deal
especially if it's toxic right and so
just goes back to challenging these
things that's all and when you can
challenge these things and you're making
a decision that's more based on
your free will we'll say
challenging the paradigms that are out
there and deciding really what serves
you
choosing what influences you're going to
have on yourself because we're always
influenced but we can choose those
influences and then choosing to
influence others instead of just being
influenced by others well now you're on
your mental point of origin right
and that's the whole show it's gonna be
about that in some way shape or form
really so yeah hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you